if not
good afternoon fellow councillors
members of staff
members of the public and media could
you please remain upstanding for the
council prayer
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance wisdom and judgment
as we face the tasks before us and
enable us now
and always worthily to discharge the
sacred trust
placed by the people in our hands
if i could just remind you we're live
streaming so
everything that happens in here it can
be observed
by the wider public interest
welcome to those who are joining live
stream
by the way where do we look
we got any apologies
there's a discussion put it to the boat
all in favor say aye
aye public forum we have david pottinger
welcome to the meeting
thank you mayor tim members of the
indica city council
i'm actually taking this opportunity to
offer you some words of encouragement
i see on the agenda there's an item
related to working
on working together and in particular
the
media protocol i was here last month and
i saw what happened when it was revealed
and that was an interesting journey
and i heard lots of things being said
about
uh lack of freedom of speech
the death of democracy as we know it we
all sorts of things
and i find it interesting because i also
watched
when uh counselor lush
was up there standing next to yourself
and reading through
what constitutes i guess the oath that
he must
follow and i guess all the other
counselors are followed
and one phrase struck me in particular
and that was
and i paraphrased here to act
in the best interests of the people of
invercargill
and in the prayer it even says the
sacred duty
and what i'm encouraging
the committee to do the council to do
over the next wee while is to remember
that
and hold that foremost in their actions
you are looking to act in the best
interests
of the people of invercargill now it's
been
discussion as to whether you need a
media protocol i know it's part of the
thompson report
uh whether we need certain constraints
i've been talking to a number of rate
payers around here no doubt
you you have as well and and a lot of
people say to me
we shouldn't need these rules we should
rely
on the good sense and sensibilities
of the people we elected to the position
of leading the city
and i happen to agree i think
what happens is there are other things
that get in the road
and that's why i encourage the council
to think about the important thing that
you have been elected here for
because in a couple of months in june
there's an important time coming up
the review of uh whether or not
the two extra learner gentlemen that we
have here
are needed now i'm sure they have other
things to do in their lives they
wouldn't be too upset
if they weren't needed after june is
that right mr mckenzie mr grant
that you could find other employment you
wouldn't be homeless wandering the
streets
and i would think instead of
because it's been budgeted for close to
three quarters of a million dollars has
been budgeted
for this exercise that's 30 per
each rate paying property and if you
said to people out there hey
thirty dollars to have these guys
they're very nice people but um
if that was more like fifteen or sixteen
dollars
then i'm sure the people of invercargill
would be saying hey
we're making progress we're doing well
they've both been involved with freezing
works and meat industries so they're
used to having changes of occupation
i'm sure unlike some of us
now i also saw the council here show a
very empathic
side when we were talking about the
increase in rents
to on the council owned properties and i
saw a very
good side of the council you were caring
about people
so all i'm saying is i encourage you
when there is discussion about what is
needed to get the council back on track
what is needed to make sure the
department of internal affairs
is not frying into our business is to
make sure that the decisions are made in
the best
interests of the people of invercargill
now if somebody's worrying what
the demise of democracy looks like i've
got one word for you
tauranga do we want to go there
do we want to be seen in that position i
don't think we do i don't think you do
i know many of you have known you for
many years i've known one of you for all
his life
i mean i know you don't want to be there
i don't know maybe i'm um i'm
acting the part of the of the the good
angels sitting on one shoulder saying
hey guys do what's right it's in the
oath
it's in the prayer and all i'm saying
is we of invercargill rely on you 13
people
to help lead us to guide us
we have faith in you so please remember
that
and i do encourage you to behave as i
know
you can so i just want to take this
opportunity thank you very much
your worship and i appreciate that
thank you any questions mr pottinger
well thank you very much for your
encouraging comments and uh
we do see the bright side of council
very often and it's
certainly we're undertaking some major
tasks in the near future so
we appreciate your support thank you for
the opportunity
interest register any changes counselors
no none receiving the confirmation of
minutes
uh oh got another screen here
minutes
[Applause]
meeting of council of the 23rd move
those your worship
thank you it's been moved secondary
moved and seconded into discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say i i
i carried minutes of an infrastructural
services committee meeting held on the
2nd of march
i will move those you worship i've seen
them your worship
thank you it's moved and seconded
questions
discussion put it to the vote all in
favor say
aye aye against carried
minutes of the performance policy and
partnerships committee held on the 9th
of march
happy to move those your worship second
your worship moved and seconded
discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say aye aye
carried the report of the
proposed road name change in relation to
the subdivision of 360
bainfield road
that council adopts the following
proposed
road name the proposed road
lots 360 be named highland
rise as it is the developer's preferred
name
and meets the council's naming
conventions
i'm happy to move that recommendation
your worship
i'll second that your worship moved and
seconded any discussion
questions put it to the verge all in
favor say aye
aye carried
now we move on to um item seven on
my screen uh we could
consider the items on the public agenda
the report of administrative matters
mr pete thompson will be here to
speak of the yeah welcome to the meeting
thank you your worship good afternoon
councillors
this uh report with the election of
councillor marcus lush puts council in a
position
where it can now determine appointments
to the various committees
subcommittees and other organizations
that have vacancies
as a result of the resignation of
council of middle
so this report outlines councillor's
current positions on the various
committees
and recommends councillors to fill the
vacant positions which are noted in red
text take the report as read and happy
to take any questions
thank you any objections
considerations all right update
uh for from project governance group
chief grant oh no better
i'm sorry there are a number
on the screen in front of us we've got
um
items from a to h well there's sorry
your worship um
if i can kick the kick things off i'm
happy to move the three recommendations
recommendation two which includes items
a to h dealing with the uh the name
councillors for
appointments and just noting that there
is still a vacancy if a council wishes
to fill uh
for an alternate on waste net
thank you for that
did everyone hear that all right one two
and three that's right
i'll seek an emotion
mr thompson if you've got no sorry
counselor cricket thank you worship um
if
there are no nominations or um
self appointments expressions of
interest
for waste net might i suggest that we
have all of council as an alternative
alternate in which case darren
or myself or councillor ludlow or myself
are not available
councillor arnold is already an
alternate yeah there's a
vacancy for another one and there's a
vacancy for a second
council of patterns i think you worship
yeah look since i'm chair of
infrastructure i think i could put my
name forward as an alternate
i mean it's a rare occasion i haven't
seen many uh 10 years i've been here
that
the alternate being used since uh
council arnold's first alternate
um i'll be second alternate
i'm happy as the mover for the motion
you worship to include
council of pottinger as the ultimate
second alternate for wasting it
comfortable at your worship as the chair
any further discussion questions
mr thompson is that all right with you
nothing further from your wishes
i'll put it to the vote all in favor say
aye aye
against carried
[Music]
report on working on working on working
on working together uh
update from project governance group
presented by
mr jeff grant thank you worship is it
okay if i do it from here
and yes thank you so this is uh
the second report in terms of the
governance group
to the council uh there are six
recommend or five recommendations and
one for noting
in terms of the progress so i'll just
briefly
run through them the first one is just
that in order for the governance group
to
work in a sensible way of seek to have a
alternate for each of the members on the
governance group which are listed there
under one
the chairs group which is chaired by
lindsay mckenzie
has got the attachment a which is the
appendix
setting out in terms of reference from
cheers group then
[Music]
under number three is the revised
debrief for the working group the
strategic projects and supporting the
ltp
this is a reflection on that particular
working group
that the view was that the progress on
the ltp
both in the workshop process and both in
the staff information and everything
was well on track and so what the ltp
progress will be for this working group
is to look at a review
post uh the ltb process
and look at setting up a mechanism for
the next ltp
and in the triannual so this is looking
forward in terms of making sure that the
process is well governed uh going
forward so that's the change that's been
made and recommended by pgg
for that particular working group
and then there's just the updated
framework for
an appendix c and then on
six which is the set out for the
methodology and timing for evaluating
progress against the report so we'll pg
g you will have heard for those that
were at the risk
and all committee risk and assurance
committee meeting yesterday for some
discussion
in terms of the um external advisors
report
that we would frame up for
pgg a slightly more
formal framework in terms of the
reporting
but also here at the sixth was that
there will be an evaluation process to
measure against that
in terms of the progress and that was
set out
in a range of
things including the workshop that i o d
surveyed
just in terms of the budget there's a
comment around the budget and it's to
say that the 310
000 allocated for all of this work
is well under that and looks to
will track well under the cost of the
310
by the 30th of june
just a couple of other matters that are
not directly
um related to that firstly is that the
progress around the draft
charter well mentioned uh is the
intention that
that will come back to council uh as
soon
as the draft is finalized and we'll
probably look at it
just having a workshop to finalize that
off uh and on the basis of that
uh lindsay and i have both expressed an
interest
that we would have a council group uh
just the councillors
we'll sit down we'd like to have a
discussion about where we've got to so
far
what bits are working in terms of our
involvement
and what bits the councillors may want
to see through to the period of 30th of
june so we'll look at trying to do that
as soon as possible
in the very near future so your worship
that saw any questions or
thank you all the recommendations would
be good questions
counselors
well there be none i'll put it we've
moved it in a second
i'll counsel a safer sorry i didn't see
you i'm happy to move the
recommendations your worship
okay i'll be having a second
discussion questions counselor
thanks your worship um look thanks jeff
for the report and for the work that
that you
and and lindsay are doing for us and and
with us
um i i take on board uh
your suggestion that we have a
counsellor only
briefing um i think it would be useful
from our perspective
the sooner that we could we could do
that the better can ask how much
time you would need to lead him before
being able to oh
i can do it tomorrow um 45 minutes and i
think we just need about 45 minutes you
know how many days you would need
to prepare for it because essentially
we've got uh two extraordinary meetings
of ppp and infrastructural services on
monday
i think if but we have a look at william
fitzson we
are happy to do it next week yep
i think i'm like you i i think lindsey
and i would be keen to do it sooner
rather than later we're just starting to
look at it
re re prioritizing around phase two and
um we'd like to raise a couple of issues
with you in
that discussion as well
thank you any further questions
counselors
well we certainly appreciate your input
yeah mr grant um
move on i don't know
put i'll put the motion all in favor say
aye aye
against carrie news reports being tabled
and just covers some topical issues
that we're dealing with like three
waters
let's do it i'll put it to the page oh
sorry i was going to move your worship
that we received
your report your table report thank you
second moved in second any discussion
the questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye aye against carried
items of urgent business
raise this part your worship
yes it's not particularly urgent but i'd
just like to make
a statement to thank the staff for all
the work they've been doing over the
last few months
and sometimes that goes unheralded i
think some of them were extremely long
hours
and i'd just like to formally say that
we all appreciate the amount of work
that's going on behind the scenes
thank you thank you for that
new items under that move
all right well we've come to the part of
the agenda
where the um uh
public are to be excluded and thank you
very much for your presence
here it certainly helps um
to see who we're actually dealing with
i'll move that with the exception of
jeff grant and lindsey mckenzie that we
go into public excluded your worship
i'll share about your worship thank you
moved and seconded in his discussion
put the vote on in favor say aye